hello there i'm nick saint and this week
we're going to say goodbye to an urban
legend mr mayards since christmas and i
wondered if i could get more carries
than you are james robinson sir i was a
pretty big deal in front of all right
let's line up your physical abuse yes
sir this is just football culture i
guess
look everyone i lit it up again i see
you someone finally sees you
pizza you're the only one i trust
prayer's up it's tim tebow the ghost of
urban past we begin at florida meyer's
past has been deemed not suitable for
any audience oh gosh i feel like my eyes
have sinned ho ho it is i chip kelly the
ghost of urban present bobby petrino had
a thing wait who am i if you play well
i'll give you a little sticker for your
helmet see the college ways don't work
in the pros be rude for me not to take a
photo
i'm not being developed right see tiny
trevor may not make it because of one
bad coach next ghost suburban future
show me how great i am
hello welcome to the big ten network
let's talk about records for 12 hours i
see now someone will always hire me you
boy my jobs are open why you're sir
huzzah a kicked goose for everyone and
everyone realized coaches should stay in
college where they are kings merry
christmas y'all